- Oh.
(laughter)
Oh.
(screaming)
(upbeat music)
- Today, we are going to be
giving our friends a couple
of Pinterest Halloween
treats, so there are going
to be three options: spooky,
spookier, and spookiest.
- Which is my face.
I really hope no one
punches me in the face.
Our first pair is coming, I'm
gonna crawl under the table,
I'm gonna remain there
the rest of the day.
I'm gonna pull my back doing
this, I know it already.
- We're trying Instagramable
Halloween treats.
- I like to trick people sometimes.
I like to be tricky and sly.
- I love Halloween.
- What are you gonna be this year?
- I don't know.
- It's the only day where I get
to dress up as someone else.
- I thought about either trick or treat.
I just got candy.
- One, two, three.
Aww.
- Aww.
They're so cute.
- That's so cute.
Is it like just a bug?
- Give it a crunch.
- I'm going to pull apart my
spider, and kill him slowly.
- It's good.
I like the salty and the sweet together.
- Yeah.
- So now we're gonna
do the spookier treat.
(gasp)
- Oh!
- Oh, yes.
- Presentation on point.
- On point.
Yes girl, those lips.
- Whoa.
I feel the spooks in my soul
- I like the candy with the chocolate.
Oh this is Reese's isn't it?
- Oh it's so much candy.
- Its an apple!
No, I didn't know.
I thought it was a cake.
I (bleep) love apples.
- This is a lot better than that shit.
- And now we're gonna try spookiest.
(screaming)
(cackles)
- That is a (bleep) ham in there.
(laughter)
- Oh.
(screaming)
Oh, my God.
I don't know if it's real!
(screaming)
- One, two, three.
- Two, three.
(screaming)
Holy shit!
- No!
What the (bleep) is wrong with you people?
(laughter)
Oh, my God.
I just nearly broke the
whole (bleep) table.
- I did not expect that.
I did not expect that.
- You got us.
- Consider me spooked.
- Yep.
You got us.
- Well that was utterly terrifying.
You ran away.
(screaming)
- I'm just gonna say
you're lucky that I didn't
smack you over the head with that pan.
- I fully thought you were going to.
- That was my second reaction.
- Look at me.
I'm shaking.
I'm really shaking.
- We (bleep) knew.
We were like...
- We knew there was something there.
Yeah, he (bleep) you up.
(laughter)
- My ass.
(upbeat music)